so how are you doing obviously it's been
about three weeks now since everything
well it's it's been great wound up
securing a caffeine deal I saw that
going going up right now I've been doing
my own pod going up right now no I saw
you were doing kind of like um more like
a mentally like a like a podcast that's
more geared towards because you're
obviously how long have you been sober
over three years well congrats thank you
um so the podcast that you've been doing
is it more like mental health directed
so there's like it's like there's
different content that I'm doing over
there one of the podcasts with uh my boy
Kyle is called Rooney hour and that is
geared towards mental health because
we're both sober right um then I have
one called lush world where I'm doing
interviews kind of similar right you got
going on and then I'm doing streams as
well so so the stream stuff's on
caffeine yeah yeah we'll congrats on
that yeah it seemed like you landed on
your feet pretty well man yep my boy EK
and the ad also was a little bit
instrumental in helping me leverage that
situation so right I think like uh for
anybody who doesn't know man I I grew up
around everybody in my family's addicts
everybody from my dad to my uncle to my
cousins
every single like big male member of my
family was some sort of addict crack
heroin I mean whatever you want to call
it right
um do you remember like uh because I was
I you know the one thing about being
somebody who loves somebody who's an
addict is the most frustrating part is
trying to get them to get clean before
they're ready to get clean it's almost
like you gotta kind of just let them
fall on their face or hit rock bottom
what was your Rock Bottom see it is
weird because my
hitting bottom is essential to getting
sober but for me there is a series of
different bottoms and I would think that
I hit bottom and then and then boom I go
down through the floorboards and then
I'm in the cellar and then boom I go
through the seller and next thing I know
I'm starting to smell sulfur and I'm
approaching the seventh layer of hell
and um yeah what was that what was the
seventh layer of Hail Rock Bottom were
you sucking dick I never suck no
[__] dick [__] hell no it was
like and then I realized when I was on
my knees about to blow this trucker for
an eight ball of coke
not just you know pitiful
incomprehensible demoralization
um just lying like being estranged yeah
my friends
um you know I'm I've experienced
anything you pretty much could besides
sucking dick
um you know I've been been shot at been
stabbed been incarcerated overdosed to
crypto times
um had hits on my life so you know yeah
I got one cousin of mine who in and out
of jail his whole life has overdosed
over and over he's been stabbed he's
been shot
I mean this dude it's it's crazy and
it's like then my Uncle Scott shout out
to Michael Scott who just got out of
prison for the [__] 98th time he just
messaged me on Facebook I could shout
Uncle Scott man welcome home Scott come
on he's like I promise you this is my
last time Kevin I hope everything's all
right like bruh
when I was a kid this dude used to come
to my house because he was tweaking so
[__] hard running around with the
Hell's Angels this [__] would be
sitting at my sink picking his [__]
face thinking there was bugs in his
[__] He's tweaking yeah
yeah so I used to go into the bathroom
be [__] blood everywhere then my
other uncle and Aunt we used to go to
their house to play with my cousins and
all the [__] spoons were burnt yeah
it's a [__] up life man yeah yeah that
attic life is serious and for you like
because there's a few different ways
obviously there's like did you go
through AA or n a rather well yeah I'm
in a 12-step program but I did go to
treatment as well and um
what when I agreed to go to treatment I
had pretty much gotten to the point
where I felt like I had no more moves
the bust I had already exhausted all my
resources right you know anybody that
was foolish enough to still be close to
me my fiance at the time any of my
friends they were like not [__] with
me and it was either that or pretty much
die I had no other options and I've been
in a lot of treatment centers over the
years the first time I was 16 you know I
went to juvie got arrested for the first
time at 13. um
I the spot that I went to was for
chronic relapsers basically it's like if
you don't get sober here it's a wrap for
you this is the last stop on the train
oh I'm aware and I um I thought that I
qualified as a chronic relapser but then
I realized I've never actually relapsed
because you wanna have a really clean
clean I never made an Earnest attempt at
sobriety in my life so yeah yeah uh one
of my uncles uh my uncle Rocky has a
drug rehab called he he was a huge
heroin addict he used to shoot up right
here damn yeah so he killed all his
veins because he had he didn't want any
anybody to see us he was shoot up in his
[__] eyelids but um this [__]
got clean started a drug rehab and then
when I was like 16 I started working for
him in like a dead and can store but he
had the same type of program called the
hard six program and it was all people
who they were like on their last they
were like habitual relapsers and man so
I was like 15 16 working in a [__] it
can store just with a bunch of [__]
recovering dope fiends yeah then I
turned 18 and I got a job running his
Consignment Car Lot literally every
employee was a [__] freshly recovered
drug addict so I was babysitting dope
fiends at 18 years old and that man
Crazy Life shout out to everybody who's
who's staying clean so for you was it
like because I was here like there's
because you know nowadays especially
being in Cali there's like weed there's
there's psychedelics there's California
silver correct right yeah so for you
You're Sober Sober yeah I can't [__]
with none of that [__] so if you smoke
weed you feel like it can kind of be a
Gateway I don't want to attempt fate you
know like I'm still high I've done
smoking so much weed in my past right so
to the point where like I have no like I
have no desire to even try it again you
know who knows in the future I just know
for right now for today I'm not [__]
with it yeah just um there was somebody
I just saw in Joe Rogan they're they're
clean and sober but they were like
considering
trying I think Ayahuasca yeah see like
you know I've already had them
psychedelic you've already had a
hardcore experiences there's no real if
I would do that for me that would be
your relapse because I just want to get
high I just want to get outside my body
but that's nothing that I can't attain
with um you know prayer meditation I can
do all that and and reach that same
level of Consciousness that's where I
don't need